If Bob knew a documentary
was being made about him,
he would act like
he didn't like it,
and he would love
every minute of it.
LARRY DAVID: Hey, Funkhouser!
I think he'd get a kick
out of the fact that I
have to sit here and do this,
knowing that
I really don't want to.
I think he would love it.
And I think he would
want to be in it,
mostly by himself.
(LAUGHS)
Ah...
There was my brother, Cliff,
Bob, and myself.
Nobody thought Bob was gonna be
any kind of an entertainer.
Did you stick a gerbil
up your ass?
-Who told you that?
-It's not important.
-No, of course I didn't
stick a gerbil up my ass!
-Don't get so upset.
STEVE MARTIN: From
Smothers Brothers Comedy Hour,
we were as close as
two people could be.
Being a guy
who loves physical comedy,
Super Dave was
must-watch-TV for me growing up.
MIKE WALDEN: Punch the bag!
CHILD: Can I have
your autograph?
Sure-- Holy shit!
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
(LAUGHING)
I was obsessed with him
instantly.
He was always very dry.
He mixed his corny old-jokes
with this weird, angry approach.
The straight man's usually what
the funny man bounces off of.
But he's both.
Did you take the flowers
at my mother's site?
-There's so many of them,
I didn't know--
-So many of them?
-Is that such a bad thing?
-You're not there to pick.
If you're lucky enough
to have a thing that works...
-Jerry, Marty Funkhouser.
-Hey, Marty, how you doing?
...that's your thing.
You don't need more
than one thing.
-(LAUGHING)
-He had a big personailty,
but a big love.
It was Bob's world,
we're only living in it.
♪ I landed on my head ♪
♪ Landed on my head